- Hi there, Rick Nicholsby,
Channel Six News.
We've had reports of
a Pegasus in the area.
Has anybody seen anything like that?
- Oh yeah, man, I seen the Pegasus.
I seen it every day.
- I seen it too, man!
We both seen that Pegasus!
- Yeah, I saw it with
my own two eyes, man.
That horse had a big old
snake head on top of it.
- Man, ain't got no snake head, fool!
Y'all that horse has some big wings, man!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That (censored) had big old wings, man!
Like two sets of wings.
Yeah, man.
Y'all see the Pegasus?
Everybody in here, seen the Pegasus, man!
(beat boxing)
(doorbell rings)
- [All] Hey!
- Hi, sweetie.
- Come check out the house.
Girl got a sunken tub, you gotta see it.
- Oh, I got to see this.
- You two have a good time now.
- Have fun, have fun.
Dude, I am sorry we're late.
- Man, it happens, man.
- She talk about how we're supposed
to be in the car at 6:45,
I'm like, all right.
- Uh oh.
- Tell me my dumb ass
ain't sitting in the car
waiting until 7:15.
- Nuh-uh.
- Okay. When I tracked my
wife down 20 minutes later,
she's stepping out the damn shower
talking about can I help you?
- You see, that's crazy right there.
- Craig, I looked this
woman in the eye, I said,
bitch, you told me 6:45.
- You said that?
- Yeah. I said-
(whispers) bitch.
Then I laid it out.
- But you said bitch, though?
- Hmm?
- You said bitch?
- Yeah.
- [Wife] You gotta see the fireplace
downstairs in the living room.
- [Wife] Okay.
- Don't play games man.
Just tell me what you're going tell me.
- Exactly.
It's like, say what you
mean, mean what you say.
- Is that so hard?
- It's like, last week, man,
we going out to dinner, right?
I'm like, where do you want to go?
She's like, you decide.
- Uh oh.
- I'm like, all right. Outback Steakhouse.
She like, nah.
I'm like straight up Chili's.
She's like eh.
- No, no.
- Daryl, I named seven more restaurants.
- No, Craig! No!
- I finally said Taylor's,
the place I know she wants
to go in the first place.
- Right!
- Right?
She look at me, she said, if
that's where you want to go.
- No, she didn't, Craig!
- "If that's where I want to go."
Daryl. I looked my
woman in the eye socket.
I told her straight out.
I just said it, man.
I said it.
I said, I said, I said-
(whispering) I said biiiii-
- Hey guys!
- Hey girl! How you doing?
Yo, you have a good time?
You seen the bedroom?
- We were just looking
at the washing machine.
- The washing machine is huge.
You get a whole bunch of clothes
in that washing machine.
- Baby, I'm gonna take
her back up to the kitchen
and show her the dishwasher.
- Hey Daryl?
- Yeah, baby?
- I want a kitchen island
just like the one upstairs.
- You gonna get it, too.
- I love you.
- I said biiiitch,
if you wanted to go to
Taylor's, just tell a brother-
- [Both] You want to go to Taylor's!
- Okay?
- You said that?
- Oh hell yeah, man.
I laid it out, right?
I says, I says, I says,
(whispering) I said biiiiitch,
I'm the man of the house.
- Yeah, you, you said bitch, though?
- Hmm?
- You called your wife a bitch?
- I, yeah.
- [Wife] Craig?
- [Wife] Daryl? Where are those guys?
- [Wife] Girl, lemme show you this.
- [Daryl] So she's like,
why don't you rent a movie we both like?
- [Craig] No, she didn't.
- After I spent 25 minutes
in the goddamn Blockbuster, Craig!
I looked this woman in her optic stems,
And I says, I said-
(whispering) I says biiiiiitch.
- You said that?
- Ain't nothing but a thing.
- But you said bitch, though.
- Yep.
(cell phone rings)
(second cell phone rings)
- Hey honey, Craig's just
giving me the neighborhood tour.
- So then she's like,
I didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking.
- Nuh-uh!
- I'm like, I didn't tell
you to wear those shoes.
She said, don't raise your voice at me.
- What?
- Daryl,
I looked this woman dead
in the windows of her soul.
I said,
(space ship door opens)
(knocks on window)
I said
biiiiiiiiiiitch-
- All right, y'all gather
round, gather round.
Welcome gentleman.
What a beautiful and
blessed day for an auction.
All right, y'all get on up there.
- Put that whip down, and
see what happens though.
- Straight up.
I don't care what plantation I end up on.
I'm straight staging a revolt
in this mother (censored).
- Hells yeah.
- We have lot A, lot B, and lot C.
- Three dollars on lot A.
- Four dollars.
- Five!
- Five dollars going once,
twice, three times sold!
Lot A goes to the man in the black hat.
- I mean, good.
- Yeah?
- I'm glad I didn't get sold,
cause I don't want to be
owned by another human being.
- Whoever buys me, they
better kill me the first day
or I'm gonna go buck wild
on the whole operation.
- Okay.
- Next one. Get up on up there now.
- Six dollars on lot A.
- [Bidder] Seven dollars!
- [Bidder] Eight!
- Nine!
- Nine dollars going once,
twice, three times sold!
- Okay well you have to buy that dude.
- It's a no brainer.
- I mean, that guy's huge.
- Massive individual.
- That's two of me.
- Anybody would buy him.
- I'd buy that dude.
- My question is, how did they catch him?
- [Auctioneer] Next!
- Okay.
- Two dollars on lot A.
- [Auctioneer] Two
dollars going once, twice,
three times sold!
- See, now that surprises me.
- That is interesting to say the least!
I mean, well it just seems
like at a certain point
it's like do they even know
what they're looking for?
- I mean like the whole criteria seems
just a little inconsistent.
- I mean at, at some point,
I, I wanna be on lot A.
- Yeah. Which that's, can
a brother get on lot A?
- Next!
- Oh, here we go.
- Here we go.
- Been a pleasure.
- Give them hell.
- All right.
- Okay.
- Eight dollars on lot A.
- Going once, twice, three times sold!
- How does that happen?
- Nope, not true.
- That's gobbledy gook.
Okay. That can't be true
cause what can this dude do?
Look at him. What could he pick?
A cotton plant is like this tall!
- Yes!
- I'm saying, no offense
brother. I'm just saying-
- Offense taken!
- Am I wrong? Is he not short?
He's short.
But you are actually short
in real life in the world.
- You're good, man.
- Enough.
I will not have my reputation tainted
selling superficial bigoted slaves.
- Superficial?
Did that really just
come out of your mouth?
- That's it!
This auction's over!
- Auction's over?
- Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It ain't over.
It's not over.
Well, I'm strong, y'all.
I'm very strong.
I can sleep in a bucket.
- I'm fast.
I got stamina.
- I know I don't look it, but-
- And I know magic.
- My worst quality is
that I'm a perfectionist.
- Have I mentioned this?
Docile. I am agreeable to a fault.
You should have seen the dude who asked me
to get on the boat when we came over here.
- Not a violent bone in my body.
- I just walked right on, no big deal.
Never seen a boat in my life.
(presidential address music)
- Good evening my fellow Americans.
Now, before I begin,
I just wanna say that I know
a lot of people out there
seem to think that I don't get angry.
That's just not true.
I get angry a lot.
It's just that the way I express passion
is different from most.
So, just so there's no more confusion.
We've hired Luther here
to be my anger translator.
Luther?
- Hi.
- First off, concerning
the recent developments
in the Middle Eastern region,
I just wanna reiterate
our unflinching support
for all people and their
right to a democratic process.
- Hey, all y'all dictators out there?
Keep messing around and see what happens.
Just see what happens.
Watch.
- Also to the governments
of Iran and North Korea,
We once again urge you
to discontinue your
uranium enrichment program.
- Hey, Mark Mo? Kim Jong?
I think I already done told
both y'all 86 your (censored).
Or I'm gonna come over
there and do it for y'all.
Please test me and see what happens.
- On the domestic front,
I just wanna say to my
critics I hear your voices
and I'm aware of your concerns.
- So maybe you can chill the
hell out for like a second,
then maybe I can focus on
some (censored), you know?
- That goes for everybody,
including members of the-.
- Oh, don't even get me started
on these (censored) right here.
- I wanna assure you
that we will be looking
for new compromises with
the GOP in the months ahead.
- And you know these
(censored) gonna say no
before I even suggest some (censored)
- Now, I know a lot of folks say
that I haven't done a good job
at communicating my
accomplishments to the public.
- Because y'all (censored) don't listen!
- Since being in office, we've
created 3 million new jobs.
- 3 million new jobs!
- We ended the war in Iraq.
- Ended the war, y'all!
We ended a war! Remember that?
- These achievements
should serve as a reminder
that I am on your side.
- (loud speaker) I am not a Muslim.
- And that my intentions as your president
are coming from the right place.
- They're coming from Hawaii,
which is where I'm from,
which is in the United States of America.
Y'all, okay?
This is ridiculous!
I have a birth certificate!
(yelling gibberish)
...birth certificate,
you dumbass crackles!
- Okay. Luther? rope it in.
- Yeah, dial it back, Luther. Damn.
- In conclusion,
last night I had a
conversation with Michelle.
- I says biiiiitch-
- Nope! I did not say that.
I did not say that.
- Mrs. Whitaker,
I have been babysitting for 20 years.
I've seen it all.
- The thing is, Forest is a unique child.
- Everything is gonna be fine.
I want you to have a good time tonight.
You deserve it.
- Okay?
Good luck.
- Thank you.
(sighing)
(suspenseful music)
- Goo goo, ga ga.
- Hey there Forest!
I want, I want milk.
- You want me to get
you your bottle, buddy?
- I want milk!
- Okay.
- This is a ba-ba!
I want mama's milk!
Why can't I have mama's milk?
It's a simple request.
- Well, yeah,
well you can't have mama's
milk right now, buddy.
How about we play?
- Okay, I want, I want,
I wanna play with my Legos.
- Okay? Yeah.
Okay buddy.
Let's get your Legos done.
- I wanna, I wanna put the
smallest Lego in my mouth.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- No, no, no. You can't.
You can't do that.
- What!
First you tell me I
can't have mama's milk.
Now I can't have a
smallest Lego in my mouth?
What a night.
This is a bad start.
- Forest, it's dangerous.
- Let me get this straight.
You are in charge of me in my house?
- Alright, Forest,
it's, it's time for bed.
- I guess then you gonna sing me a song?
- What?
- Mom always sings me a
song before go to sleep.
You gonna do that for me?
- Okay.
Yeah. Yes, I will.
♪ Hush little baby ♪
♪ Don't say a word ♪
- Keep keep singing.
♪ Mama's gonna buy you a mocking bird ♪
- Put my name in there.
I like, I like it personal.
♪ Hush baby Forest Whitaker ♪
♪ Don't say a word ♪
- Goo goo, ga ga.
♪ Momma's gonna buy you a mocking bird ♪
- Good babysitter.
♪ And if that mocking bird don't sing ♪
- Have a good cry.
(crying)
♪ Mama's gonna buy you a diamond ring ♪
- Drew, come forward.
- Yes Chef.
This is a chicken quiche
with cremini mushrooms,
baby spinach and feta cheese.
(suspenseful music)
- Unbelievable.
Well Drew, I have a huge
problem with this dish.
It's that you haven't
made it for me sooner.
- Thank you, Chef.
- Because if you had Drew,
then I would know how good
you are at cooking food.
That's bad.
- I'm sorry Chef.
- And when I say bad, I
mean Michael Jackson Bad.
- Thank you Chef.
- You know how he looked
really, really bad
at the end of his life?
- Chef, I'm sorry.
I don't know if you like the dish or not.
- You don't know if you
like the dish or not?
Well, let's put it this way.
Pack your (censored) knives, get out.
You're off the show-
- Sorry, Chef.
- Because you should be working
in the finest restaurant in the world.
- Thank you, Chef.
- Just not any world that I live in.
- Sorry, Chef.
- Because frankly Drew,
I'm jealous of you.
- Thank you, chef.
- And your ability to
not give a (censored)
about what you cook.
This is not fit for human consumption.
No. This should be eaten
by a higher life form
with a more complex palate,
but also an altruistic
drive to save humanity
from dishes like this.
Joking. Not!
You deserve to die!
So you won't have to
endure a life in which you
will never exceed what you
have achieved here today.
(bright music)
- Thank you Chef.
- In conclusion?
Eh.
- Mm mm.
Come on man.
What you doing, man?
That's stupid.
That's stupid, man.
Don't do that, man.
Come on!
- Are you kidding me?
- [Key] Come on, man.
Don't go in there.
Do not go into a crane shot right now.
You kidding me?
- Yeah man.
Hell y'all, this movie's got
an inconsistent visual language.
- [Key] Half the time this
(censored) just shooting all
handheld like your a dogma filmmaker.
That's funny.
Since dogma clearly forbids
temporal and geographical alienation.
(shocking scene, audience jumps)
- Oh, I loved that shot the first time
when it was in Nosferatu!
- Yeah, that's right.
I mean (censored) trying to do some homage
to the German expression.
It's a (censored).
- It's a visual medium, man.
Enough with this, My Dinner
With Andre (censored)
- I mean has this dude
even heard of his own song?
Put some information
up in the frame, bitch!
- I get it.
Yeah. I'm overexposed film.
Getting the Fario look.
Man, (censored)!
- Can we just go?
- Hold on.
They're actually making good points.
Hey, has this guy watched too much
Quentin Tarantino or what?
- Sir, we're gonna need
you to lower your voice.
Too much talking.
Okay. Thank you.
I talked to him Sir,
he's not gonna bother you anymore.
- Thank you.
- What do we do?
They told us at the station to
come down here and fill time.
But there's no story here.
- In this neighborhood,
there's always a story.
Here, gimme the name
of a mythical creature.
- Mythical, I don't-
- Trust me.
I don't know.
A Pegasus.
- Pegasus. Perfect.
Just roll, watch and learn.
(van door slams shut)
- But they can stay in
my house if they want to.
- Hi there Rick Nicholsby,
Channel Six News.
We've had reports of
a Pegasus in the area.
Has anybody seen anything like that?
- Oh yeah, man, I've seen a Pegasus.
I've seen it.
Yeah. Every day!
- I seen it too, man!
We both seen that Pegasus!
- Yeah, I saw em with
my own two eyes, man!
That horse had a big
old snake head on top-
- Ain't got no snake head, fool.
Y'all that horse had some big wings, man!
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The (censored) had big old wings, man!
Like two sets of wings.
Yeah, man!
Y'all see the Pegasus?
Everybody up in here
seen the Pegasus, man!
- [Announcer] Curiosity has
brought out large crowds
to see the alleged Pegasus
in this South Lennox neighborhood.
- Look, there it is.
- I'm going to find it.
Break it and then ride it
to the Pegasus treasure.
- [[Announcer] Residents say the creature
resembles this amateur sketch.
- Kicked the (censored) out of my car.
City's gotta pay for that (censored) too.
I ain't got no coverage
with no packages, bitch.
- He laying at my roof.
Man, look at my roof, man.
He busted it up.
He busted the whole thing up, man!
Yeah, he been, he been,
he been sitting up there every day!
- [Announcer] While many
revel in the possibility
of seeing the winged horse,
others are not so welcoming.
- I just know this
neighborhood will be better
if that Pegasus is put down.
- I tell you this, God ain't
putting no wings on no horse.
- Now see if this was
a white neighborhood,
animal control would be up
in here with a Pegasus trap.
- That's right!
They can't take our Pegasus!
This is our Pegasus!
Yeah, Pegasus up in
this mother (censored)!
- Hey man, why you interrupting me?
I'm trying to talk about the Pegasus.
- Hey (censored)!
- Hey, don't be disrespecting the Pegasus!
I love Pegasus!
(news jingle)
- Yes. We're here live on the scene
in South Lennox where
riots have broken out
over the alleged appearance
of a flying horse.
(car alarms sounding, people yelling)
(upbeat music)